Try to just listen and I think it's more not as much advice,...
...but when I see people who are living fully who they are,...
...who are honestly who they are,...
...who believe what they believe and who stand by it, I know that that's right.
And when I see people who are trying to be something they're not...
...or not speaking their whole truth, I feel very uncomfortable for them.
I think in this life, is very short, in fact...
...and there is no time to be small or selfish...
...or distracted by material possessions or cruelty or opinions...
...or just that you have to just be fully as you are...
...and know your voice and stand by it...
...because I think somebody said once it's not what you do,...
...it's what you choose not to do.